bonjour à tous ça me fait vraiment très
plaisir d'être là avec vous aujourd'hui
le sujet que j'ai envie de vous parler
aujourd'hui ça va traiter des rêves
c'est un sujet qui me passionne depuis
vraiment très longtemps depuis tout
petit en fait c'est un traité qui est un
sujet qui a été traité des milliers de
fois par des milliers d'auteurs pour ça
je vous racontais des petites histoires
en cascade et je vais vous faire un
petit peu participé aussi ça vous va est
ce donc la première question que j'ai
envie de vous poser c'est là tout de
suite maintenant est-ce que vous pensez
que vous êtes éveillé qui pensent qu'il
est éveillée ici ok 1 pas tout le monde
qui pensent qu'il entendrait des
personnes ok donc la question que j'ai
envie de vous poser c'est comment vous
savez que vous êtes éveillé parce que
quand vous êtes en train de rêver la
nuit ça vous paraît normal vous avez des
des rêves vous ressentez des sensations
et pourtant vous êtes en train de dormir
donc la première chose que j'ai envie de
vous faire là tout de suite c'est vous
faire participer
vous allez prendre deux doigts comme ça
allez-y voilà rassurés vous normalement
c'est pas dangereux
vous allez vous passer le nez allez-y
passé vous lever jusqu'à ce que vos
narines soit bouché et vous allez
essayer d'inspirer malgré qu'elle soit
bouché allez-y voilà donc normalement ça
marche pas puisque vos narines sont
bouchées ok vous allez bien à quoi ça
sert tout ça c'est assez simple si vous
arrivez à respirer sachant que votre nez
il est bouché et un problème donc
peut-être que vous n'êtes pas dans la
réalité
en revanche si vous boucher le nez que
vous arrivez à respirer ça veut dire que
probablement il ya quelque chose qui
cloche donc que vous êtes en train de
rêver vous me suivez
ok
ça s'appelle un test de réalité en fait
c'est parmi les ravers professionnels
ils ont toute une panoplie de d'outils
comme ça pour savoir s'ils sont en train
de rêver et celui que vous venez de
faire en état pour continuer je vais
vous raconter des histoires ok la
première histoire que je vais vous
raconter c'est celle d'un enfant qui
avait un rêve
oui c'est très original donc c'est le
petit enfant il converse les parents
comme ça ta maman papa maman ça y est je
sais ce que je veux faire plus tard et
le papa il répond elle est c'est reparti
en fait je veux devenir archéologue
archéologues
qu'est ce que c'est que ça bah si
archéologues comme ça je pourrais
déterrer des os de dinosaures faire des
grands ce que l'étudiant comme ça elle
aimait tant des musées et les gens il
pourrait venir voir ça ouais ouais
d'accord ok bon c'est bien mais sinon
comme vrai métier tu vas faire quoi plus
tard mais non mais c'est ça que je veux
faire c'est ça que je veux faire mais
non mais comme vrai métier médecins
avocats
nous allons analyser ensemble les
changes qui a eu entre le petit et son
papa il ya eu une interaction mais qui a
été très rapide c'est juste quelques
phrases quelques mots qui sont échangés
ici et là parmi les mots du papa ya quoi
il ya non mais un vrai métier là ça
commence à être intéressant comme s'il y
aurait des vrais métiers et d'un autre
côté par déduction défaut métier ok
c'est quoi un faux métier est-ce qu'il y
en a parmi vous qui savent ce que c'est
des faux métier vous savez il faut
boulanger ou info boucher qui fait du
faux pain ou la fausse viande et ouais
mais ce qui est encore plus rigolo c'est
que c'est ce que le petit a déduit le
papa il a pas dit qu'ils avaient des
vrais métiers défaut métier il a juste
dit il ya des vrais métiers
par déduction le petit va se dire un à
l'arrière défaut métiers du coup ensuite
il a utilisé d'autres mots du coup il y
aurait et ensuite à la fin vous souvenez
il a dit médecin ou avocat
forcément parce que dans les vrais
métiers il ya soit médecin soit avocat
il ya aucun autre métier d'accord donc
ça s'appelle comment ça s'appelle de l'
influence en fait le petit il est en
train de se faire influencer
sauf que ça va très rapidement c'est à
dire c'est quoi au delà des mots qu'est
ce qu'on trouve des émotions des regards
une intensité
il ya aussi des soupirs par exemple
quand le papa est fait mais oui mais oui
c'est bien et bien fait comment ça
s'appelle ça ça s'appelle de la
communication les changes qui a eu là
c'est une communication entre un petit
et son papa ça va très très vite
c'est comme s'il y avait finalement deux
mondes le monde du petit où tout est
possible
en fait c'est ça les enfants il arrive à
rêver les yeux ouverts
il rêve éveillé avec les yeux ouverts
ils ont pas besoin d'attendre la nuit il
court partout il ya beaucoup d'énergie
et beaucoup d'émotion et instantanément
il arrive à créer une multitude de
réalité face à ça il ya le papa avec sa
vision un peu plus cadré où il y aurait
les vrais métiers défaut métier
probablement dans les faux métier dans
les vrais métiers y aurait des métiers
qui sont pénibles tout ça mais c'est pas
grave il faut les faire vous comprenez
donc qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
comme si en grandissant le petit père
ses rêves
c'est comme si l'année une réserve
finances dans ses poches et qu'on fur et
à mesure il avancé il comme s'il perdait
sa capacité de rêver encore une petite
histoire par rapport à moi quand j'étais
petit mes rêves c'était d'être
architecte je voulais être architecte et
au début je savais que c'était possible
je savais que j'allais devenir
architecte
c'est qu'après en grandissant en
grandissant j'ai commencé à me dire des
choses du style c'est trop compliqué
peut-être qu'à passer travail je suis
pas assez bon en mathématiques
connaissez ça vous parle ces petites
phrases là qu'on se répète donc on nous
répète content grandit donc la question
c'est la suivante comment l'adulte il
pourrait faire pour réactiver sa
capacité à rêver comment il pourrait
faire comme l'enfant de quoi il a besoin
finalement et pour ça je vais vous
parler encore d'autres histoires
une histoire que et d'autres personnages
ok parmi ces personnages là on pourrait
commencer à s'inspirer des adultes qui
continue de rêver mais ça existe et
encore des adultes qui ont gardé ça
comme s'ils avaient leur âme d'enfant
sur vous en connaissez on les distingue
souvent ils ont l'oeil brillant
ils ont ce petit côté espiègle ils ont
tout le temps envie de jouer rêver d'une
certaine manière
ici on commence à s'inspirer de ces
personnes là on peut redonner à l'adulte
sa capacité à arriver parmi ces
personnes là je vais vous parler de d'un
des plus grands hypnothérapeute qui a
existé au travers de l'histoire qui
s'appelait milton erickson milton
erickson c'était un psychiatre américain
qui a vécu entre 1900 et 1980 et qui
était un des meilleurs hypnothérapeute
il aimait beaucoup joué avec ses rêves
en fait
milton erickson il était il avait gardé
cette espèce de contact avec son
intérieur
quand on parle de mon intérieur de
l'enfant le jeu tout ça
finalement c'est quoi c'est le monde de
l'inconscient tout ça c'est le monde de
la nuit
la nuit ya pas de limite les milton
erickson
il aimait bien jouer avec son
inconscient il était devenu tellement
fort en auto hypnose qu'ils aient
commencé à programmer des choses à faire
pendant la nuit
oui vous avez entendu faire des choses
par exemple écrire des articles son
grand truc à milton erickson c'était se
lever la nuit dans un état somnambulique
ils s'asseyent à son bureau
ça m'a attrapé un stylo il commence à
écrire des articles comme ça ensuite il
reposait le stylo il allait se coucher à
nouveau il avait une amnésie et le matin
il avait comme une fleur sur sa table de
chevet il y avait un article écrit par
son inconscient et comme il était
vraiment connecté à son monde intérieur
il faisait vraiment confiance à ça à
cette magie en fait à cette puissance et
ils envoyaient tel quel son article à
une journal scientifique qui allait le
publier c'est pas mal quand même non
vous imaginez là pour votre dm de maths
le lundi vous lever la nuit
si on continue dans la direction des
rêves qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pendant la nuit pendant les rêves qui
est juste impossible dans le monde
matériel on va dire comme volé par
exemple qui a déjà volé dans ses rêves
hockey qui se souvient de la sensation
qu'on ressent quand on est en train de
voler dans les rêves
ouais ok mais c'est pas génial comme
sensation enfin je veux dire c'est pas
lundi matin quand on va au boulot tous à
un métro qu'on a ce genre de sensations
là quand on est en train de rêver donc
on voi comme ça on survole des des
collines des montagnes on peut même
survolé jean sérien new york où d'autres
villes comme ça et ça c'est grâce à l'un
conscient et l'inconscient il est
tellement fort qu'il arrive à recalculer
comme si c'était vrai en fait comme si
vous vouliez vraiment sans elle mais
avec votre corps vous ressentez levant
toutes ces choses là ça devient réel ok
alors qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
d'autres qui est intéressant dans les
rêves
le monde de la nuit ce qui est bien avec
tout ça c'est qu'on commence à faire
sauter les limites mentales
quand on se met à voler quand on se
reconnecte à ça on est capable de faire
des choses impossibles
d'autres choses qui sont vraiment
intéressants c'est au niveau des
rencontres qu'on peut faire qui a déjà
ici rencontrer des personnages qu'ils
auraient pas pu rencontrer dans la
réalité dans les rêves n'ont même pas
mal ok ok moi par exemple dans mes rêves
j'avais rencontré françois mitterrand
donc j'ai aucune affinité avec françois
mitterrand
mais bon il est décédé il ya un moment
et je me souviens de ce rêve là où je le
rencontre est donc déjà c'est un grand
monsieur
quand même enfin peut-être pas de taille
mais vous avez compris et donc j'ai
commencé à parler un françois mitterrand
et il a commencé à me donner des
conseils
c'est rigolo je lui posais des questions
et donner des conseils et donc moi
j'écrivais précieusement les conseils
l'équipe donné mais en fait c'est
bizarre parce que qui en train de rêver
c'est moi c'est mon subconscient qui
crée un monde dans lequel je donne de
l'expérience de quelque chose c'est
bizarre non quand même
et par rapport à ça je veux raconter
encore une autre histoire
donc ça ça arrive est un très bon ami à
moi donc il était en train de rêver et
il était fan de jean jacques goldman
vous connaissez le chanteur hockey qui
va au bout de ses rêves
donc il rencontre jean jacques goldman
dans son rêve donc déjà dans la réalité
ça aurait été un petit peu plus
compliqué de faire ça parce qu'il n'est
pas inabordable quelque part mais c'est
quand même une star il est quand même
très sollicité ça aurait été compliqué
donc lui la nuit il est allé le
rencontrer
et pareil c'est un des meilleurs moments
de sa vie
il m'a dit parmi les expériences que
j'ai vécues celle là c'est une des plus
fortes parce que il était là avec son
idole et là jean jacques goldman et
commence à composer un air au piano
compose un héros piano ensuite mon ami
commence à fredonner une petite chanson
il s'assoit à côté comme ça
il commence à créer une chanson ensemble
donc là ça devient encore plus fort et
émotionnellement
il crée sa ensembles et à ce moment là
il m'a dit gilles je savais que j'étais
en train de rêver à ce moment là je
savais qu'il fallait absolument que je
me réveille que j'aille enregistrés ça
donc il se dit cependant le rêve quand
on est quand on est lucide comme ça ça
s'appelle un rêve lucide ce qu'ils ont
déjà fait ça c'est en fait vous savez
que vous êtes en train de rêver donc il
sera dit comme ça il a les yeux grands
ouverts
il fonce il va attraper son dictaphone
et là c'est le drame mesdames et
messieurs l'amnésie
finalement il n'a jamais retrouvé son
air c'est dommage pour lui donc
reprenons
quand on est petit on a cette capacité
n'est arrivé c'est facile on rêve les
yeux ouverts
au fur et à mesure qu'on grandit on perd
cette capacité là dommage est de plus en
plus on commence au lieu d'avoir des
métiers du style archéologues chercheurs
de trésors ou des métiers comme ça
finalement on veut faire de la finance
ou voyez ce que je dis et ensuite quand
on se remet à rêver comme milton
erickson comme ces gens là qui font de
l'hypnose est l'auto hypnose
on peut commencer à prendre des
capacités comme ça et là si on commence
à se dire mais comment je pourrais
utiliser ça pour continuer d'avancer
comme un petit peu avec jean jacques
goldman ou ou là on est carrément dans
un processus de création dans un
processus de création d'innovations
musicales artistiques
on peut l'utiliser comme ça on peut
l'utiliser au niveau de la recherche
avec milton erickson qui écrivait des
articles grâce à son inconscient du coup
on se dit comment on pourrait aller
encore plus loin que ça comment on
pourrait utiliser ses capacités là
imaginez si tout ça on utilise dans le
monde de demain dans le monde de
l'entreprise
imaginez ce que ça pourrait donner par
exemple dans un cabinet d'architecturé
si on commence à utiliser ça ça
donnerait quelque chose comme ça un
employé qui appelle son patron et tu vis
d écouter monsieur j'ai un problème
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui vous arrive bah c'est
pendant la nuit ça dérape et non pas
encore vos rêves machin si si si on a
conscience il a tout fait du coup il ya
des croquis partout dans ma chambre des
feuilles a3 des feuillets de tous les
calculs sont faits j'ai un mois d'avancé
sur le projet vous imaginez ça voudrait
dire que dans les entreprises il y
aurait des changements en profondeur
comme ça les changements structurels de
l'entreprise dans les entreprises il
commencerait à enlever les bureaux il
installerait dès liés à la place
vous rigolez mais depuis quelques années
il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de bruit
autour des siestes par exemple entre
midi et deux la nouvelle tendance à new
york à paris tout ça c'est les siestes
barre vous connaissez les césar c'est un
bar où le prendre un café en fait une
sieste
parce qu'ils ont commencé à se rendre
compte que les siestes c'était très
réparateur pour le cerveau quand vous
imaginez il va enlever les bureaux vont
mettre des liens la place ensuite c'est
les hommes politiques les hommes
politiques ils vont s'emparer du truc
ils vont dire surfer sur la vague avec
des slogans novateur dormir plus pour
produire plus les anciens fainéants
seront idolâtré rendez compte celui qui
dormaient près du radiateur l'un au fond
de la classe
ce sera la nouvelle élite de la nation
parce qu'il sera beaucoup plus productif
que ses collègues
ok du coup au départ je vous avez fait
vous souvenez en effet le petit est
comme ça l'an à faire un deuxième test
vous êtes prêts
pas dangereux normalement oui vous allez
mettre votre main sur la tête comme ça
voilà super tout le monde tout le monde
et vous allez faire rebondir la main
comme ça voilà et d'un que vous allez
faire
encore mieux que ça ok vous pouvez vous
a plu voilà donc là c'était un test pour
moi en fait comme il ya 150 personnes
qui font n'importe quoi
je dois être en train de rêver merci